[Music]
kicking things off with some breaking
news as wildfires rage across Southern
California et has learned that flames
have reached the bachelor mansion Wow et
Jojo Corral has been monitoring the
blazes all day Jojo what can you tell us
about that iconic house hey guys well as
you just mentioned you know we learned
at the mansion is on fire there's no
other details at the moment we did see
that the creator of the bachelor
franchise Micra is tweeted this morning
that he was scared that the flames would
reach the mansion and it's so
unfortunate that it's true I've seen the
house before and it's definitely right
in the middle of Malibu so it's just
very unfortunate so do we know if they
were in the middle of production was
anyone at the house was it a hot fit we
don't we don't know that but you know
all we know right now is that you know
it's currently on fire and hopefully
we'll get more details soon absolutely
other Hollywood properties that have
been affected by this have been the
west-world said tell us about that yeah
well we learned that a western town
which is located on the Paramount ranch
burned down it's a popular shooting
location for shows like Westworld and
also The Mentalist
weeds we actually heard from HBO West
Worlds Network that's they they told us
that the show wasn't in production so
luckily no one from the show was hurt
but it's not the only step from the show
but it's a very prominent set that I
think a lot of people would recognize
they watch the show and this is a very
historic location right the Paramount
ranch has been around what since 1927 so
this is a devastating loss for Hollywood
it is it is lots of films lots of shows
definitely a devastating loss star Evan
Rachel Wood had tweeted this morning
this is eerie so sad for the history
loss amazed the church is still standing
hashtag surreal so this is I mean this
is this
Jojo is affecting everyone here in the
Greater Los Angeles I think you're so
powerful yeah it is yeah when you look
at that photo it's extremely eerie and
she talks about the church being
untouched and you know these you see the
photo of her on set and it's just it's
just tragic
[Music]